oh rice is eaten by about half of the
world's population as a global staple
food keeping its price low means less
people in the world go to bed hungry but
food prices around the world are under a
triple threat including the war in
Ukraine with the termination of the
Black Sea initiative the most vulnerable
we'll pay the highest price
extreme heat waves and wildfires
destroying farmland
as well as torrential flooding washing
away crops potential profits and farmers
livelihoods in the process
last year India exported 22 million tons
of rice to more than 140 countries but
that's all about to change with the
export ban on non-basmati Rice coming
into place
Sandeep chaprana a farmer in uttar
Pradesh State supports 18 people he took
out a loan of eight thousand dollars
hoping to make a profit on his next
Harvest
we had no flood warning we had prepared
and had sold our land but now the entire
investment is lost as you can see the
rice paddy has been destroyed this is
going to hit our livelihood and survival
this rice exporte New Delhi has his own
specialized brand of rice that goes to
Singapore a ban on exports he says
directly impacts his Revenue
for exporters their business will come
to a halt eventually there will be
losses all the people employed in the
business will sit idle the government
will lose tax revenue and the ban will
also affect farmers
analysts aren't convinced the Indian
government's export ban will have the
desired effect the question is would
this impact even be enough to contain
inflation
you see the the the aim of this decision
after all is to you know prevent food
inflation in India from rising I'm not
sure if this is sufficient
Global food prices are turning out to be
another casualty of the war in Ukraine
and Global warming's influence on
weather patterns is placing increasing
strain on global food production and
food security Mike leppel Al Jazeera
thank you